[Aplausos]
la oposición al gobierno de Gustavo
Petro midió su fuerza en las calles en
Bogotá unas 5000 personas participaron
en la denominada marcha de la mayoría
según datos de las autoridades locales
la principal Consigna no más Petro y
fuera Petro una señal del de rechazo de
ciertos sectores de la oposición no solo
a las políticas gubernamentales sino la
figura del presidente para defender la
democracia y la libertad para defender
la independencia de poder en las
instituciones que hoy están en riesgo
por cuenta del escándalo que protagoniza
Gustavo Petro y su familia y el círculo
cercano esta jornada de protestas
antigubernamentales la segunda más
grande en menos de un año llegan un
momento de crisis política para Gustavo
Petro las denuncias de medios locales
sobre presunta corrupción en la
financiación de su campaña presidencial
así como escándalos en su círculo
cercano de gobierno afectaron la imagen
del mandatario de izquierda según
sondeos un nuevo capítulo de la crisis
sucedió Este martes luego de que el
poder legislativo tumbara la reforma
laboral una de las propuestas clave del
proyecto del cambio parece que las
reformas son mal planeadas mal pensadas
inconvenientes para el país pero lo peor
de todo me parece rendirle culto a todos
los billos y escudarse en
narcotraficantes en guerrilleros los de
las en un encuentro con las fuerzas
militares el presidente de Colombia Se
pronunció sobre las protestas Esa es la
expresión del talante democrático
el que aquí se puedan expresar como
quieran siempre que se respeten los
derechos
contra el mismo gobierno y no pase nada
tanto la oposición como el oficialismo
calientan motores para las elecciones
locales que tendrán lugar en octubre